[Musique]
les enfants n'a pas loin de parler
politique fois et c'est dur à nous
exprimer pour la politique parce que le
nain qui savent pas à quoi dire parce
qu'ils savent pas s'ils sont de gauche
ou de droite c'est plutôt les parents
qui sage et toi est-ce que tu as une
opinion pas
je sais pas de quel parti charest ment
parce que io na na qui disent la vérité
d'auray dans la gauche et de la droite
il y en a qui disent même on change
l'eau c'est pas les départager oui mais
quand même la politique c'est un travail
sérieux pour gouverner la france c'est
long ça va mal la gauche je crois que
c'est les communistes ou le contraire
les la droite socialiste on m'a jamais
vraiment bien expliquer parce que à
chaque fois que j'ai demandée en mariage
et c'est très utile pour comprendre là
et est ce que toi tu penses que tu es
trop petit pour comprendre
il ya des moments où je me dit cui et
d'autres non
parce que il ya des moments où je suis
comment dire coucou fatigué au genou
fiche un peu de tout alors je pense plus
qu'à une seule chose leur maudite où je
comprendrais jamais payé il ya des tas
d'autres choses je me sens en forme que
j'ai envie de faire beaucoup de choses
là je crois que j'ai envie de comprendre
et je crois que je peux
[Musique]
la cohabitation qu'est ce que ça veut
dire même si les disputes entre la
droite et la gauche
en émission
les disputes dans une émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la gauche alors pour moi
c'est tout ce que j'aime bien
il ya droit c'est tout ce que j'aime pas
et alors pourquoi tu ne les aime pas
c'est ce que j'aime pas parce qu'ils
sont j'ai trouvé
je ne pas leur ai déjà ne pas leur façon
de parler j'aime tout ce qui sort à
gisèle j'aime pas
mais comme elle a pu le faire déjà une
idée comme ça au fond regardant quelques
fois des infos en jeter un petit coup
d'oeil sur les journaux moi j'aime bien
la droite parce que quand ils disent
quelque chose pour nous à l'air sérieux
mais quand la droite contre la gauche
dit quelque chose par exemple fabius ben
ils ont pas l'air y dix ans on s'en fout
temps mais quand c'est quand la droite
ils disent ça en
sérieux et ils tiennent un peu quand
même leurs promesses ils ne tiennent pas
tout le temps mais presque tapez mieux
le faire on s'en foutait de la sphère
code
d'avoir l'air sérieux et pas faible
pour quatre ans il en a qui me
déplaisent elle semblait qu'elle
chaumeil open
comment je vais dire
jacques toubon
et voilà parce que je tout bon je suis
pas mais pas mais m'énerve menergy
m'énerve parce que on apprenne sentiment
qu'ils veulent nous gouverner
je sais pas mais ils veulent nous
gouverner comme eux comme des
marionnettes quoi
et comment tu as que ce pressentiment
comme tu dis
ce que les autos de parler par le com
comme si à roye parler à son serviteur
j'aime bien géré ce giscard d'estaing
lui gouverne bien son peuple quand il
dit quand il était
président méthodique et là j'entends
quand il était président j'étais assez
petit
tu te souviens
[Musique]
qu'il faudrait qu'ils soient en jean ou
en pantalon de velours
sans cravate parce que ça fait un peu ça
fait un peu vieux
puis on dirait qu'ils vont un
enterrement il faut qu'il soit y élégant
dont il faut bien qu'il faut qu'il est
habile beaux
costumes ils sont bien comme ça ça fait
la rend plus vieux plus
sage est un canal enfin tout le temps
être aux cravates pas quand même changé
un peu
près se déguiser en je ne l ai dit nous
en cuir peuvent faire ça par exemple une
fois le trimestre forum timide comme ça
rigolo pour pas que ça se paye toujours
côté pour moi batailler patalas
[Musique]
son la femme politique un mot seriez
donc on a ça me traite pas les femmes
politiques sur un carnage les railleries
il faut payer
parce que
l'aveyron a contrario le signer puis à
venir à bayonne c'est bon si tout
est pourquoi tu crois que les hommes au
mieux oui mais ils y réfléchissent
anticipe quelque chose
alors que les fans
comptaient ouvrir des trucs intéressants
tout de suite moi je ne m'a pas être une
femme politique parce que on se bagarre
souvent enfin se dispute souvent et puis
comme je suis nerveuse je m'énerverais
facilement
alors qu'est ce que tu fais
ouais je crierai je serais pas content
est ce que toi plus tard tu aimerais
être un homme politique
lancée de jeu ne devrait pas bousculer
par quoi la parfois
j'appelle micro et je cents à commencer
par l'hôtel mais aussi souvent on est
comment dire
on est pourri par l'argent il trempe où
on se croit un peu trop pour quelqu'un
de bien et puis on se permet à peu des
initiatives qui sont pas bien puis sont
pas si pourri que ça mange trouve très
iiième république ils ont pas qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus que les autres
les noms une voiture normale et
puis quand tu passes atteignant le pas
pu remarquer que michel drucker starsky
et hutch
moi je préfère en faire pas être
président je préfère être quelqu'un de
moyens qui gagne quand même un peu sa
vie et puis c'est tout je préfère être
président parce que jade riz tous ceux
qui sont qu'ils ont du mal à survivre et
puis après deuxième chose à faire est
belge je profiterai j'en profiterais
j'en prends je profiterai d'être
président je les petits moments de temps
libre j'en profiterai pour aline
benyettou
filtré
[Musique]